OFFICIAL TRYING TO KEEP THAT
SHIP FROM DOCKING IN FLORIDA.
>> NEW MENTALITY, NEW CULTURE
OF HOSPITALS WORKING WITH ONE
ANOTHER, BOTH WITHIN THE PUBLIC
SYSTEM AS WELL AS THE PRIVATE
SYSTEM.
THIS IS GOING TO BE ALL HANDS
ON DECK.
THIS IS EVERYBODY HELPING
EVERYONE ELSE.
ONE HOSPITAL GETS OVERWHELMED,
THE OTHER HOSPITALS HAVE TO
FLEX TO HELP THAT HOSPITAL AND
VICE VERSA.
>> Sandra: NEW YORK HOSPITALS
GEARING UP FOR A SURGE OF NEW
PATIENTS IN THE COMING WEEKS AS
STATE AND CITY LEADERS FIGHT TO
FLATTEN THE CURVE ON THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC.
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS RISING
DRAMATICALLY IN NEW YORK IN THE
PAST SEVERAL DAYS.
MOST OF THEM IN NEW YORK CITY.
DAVID LEE MILLER IS LIVE FOR US
IN MANHATTAN THIS MORNING.
A MAKESHIFT FIELD HOSPITAL IS
BEING BUILT IN CENTRAL PARK.
>> SANDRA, NEW YORKERS ARE VERY
JADED BUNCH.
NOW MANY SIMPLY CANNOT BELIEVE
WHAT THEY SEE TAKING PLACE IN
CENTRAL PARK.
BEHIND ME A TENT CITY,
TEMPORARY HOSPITAL BEING
CONSTRUCTED.
THE LOCATION HERE DIRECTLY
ACROSS THE STREET FROM NEW
YORK’S MT. SINAI HOSPITAL, A
HOSPITAL HERE LIKE SO MANY
STRUGGLING TO COPE WITH THE
INCREASING NUMBER OF VIRUS
PATIENTS.
THE ROADWAY SEPARATING THE
HOSPITAL AND CENTRAL PARK’S
FIFTH AVENUE, A STREET THAT HAS
SOME OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE REAL
ESTATE IN THE WORLD.
NOW HERE AT THIS LOCATION IN
CENTRAL PARK SINCE SUNDAY, THIS
TENT CITY HAS BEEN UNDER
CONSTRUCTION.
BY THE TIME IT’S DONE ON
TUESDAY, THERE WILL BE 14 TENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN CONSTRUCTED.
ABOUT HALF THAT MANY HAVE NOW
BEEN SET UP.
THIS IS THE WORK OF A GROUP
CALLED SAMARITAN’S PURSE BASED
IN NORTH CAROLINA.
THEY HAVE BROUGHT WITH THEM AS
MANY AS 60 HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS INCLUDING
DOCTORS, NURSES AND PARAMEDICS.
MAYOR BILL DEBLASIO SAYS HE IS
GRATEFUL FOR THE HELP.
>> WE WILL BE USING EVERY PLACE
WE NEED TO USE TO HELP PEOPLE.
MT. SINAI HOSPITAL WORKING WITH
SAMARITAN’S PURSE IS CREATING A
68-BED FIELD HOSPITAL.
THIS IS THE KIND OF THING
YOU’LL SEE AS THIS CRISIS
DEVELOPS AND DEEPENS.
>> AMONG THE 68 BEDS THAT THE
MAYOR TALKED ABOUT, 10 WILL BE
INTENSIVE CARE CAPABLE EQUIPPED
WITH VENTILATORS, NEW YORK
CONTINUES THE RACE AGAINST TIME
TO INCREASE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
HOSPITAL BEDS BEFORE THE VIRUS
REACHES ITS APEX AND OTHER HELP
HAS ALREADY ARRIVED.
A PLANE FROM CHINA TOUCHED DOWN
AT NEW YORK’S JFK APORT.
ON BOARD MORE THAN 100,000
MASKS, SURGICAL MASKS AND GOWNS
AND MORE THAN A MILLION GLOVES.
SUPPLIES WERE BROUGHT HERE
CALLED PROJECT AIR BRIDGE.
PARTNERSHIP OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
FEMA WILL DISTRIBUTE SUPPLIES
TO THE NEW YORK REGIONS AND
OTHER HIGH RISK AREAS.
THE MEASURES PUT IN PLACE BY
CITY AND STATE APPEAR TO BE
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
LATEST STATISTICS SHOW THE
NUMBER OF HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE
NOW DOUBLING AT A RATE OF ONLY
IF YOU WILL, ONLY DOUBLE EVERY
SIX DAYS.
MEANWHILE, THE DEATH RATE,
THOUGH, CONTINUES TO RISE.
SANDRA.
>> Sandra: WHAT A SIGHT THAT IS
IN THE MIDDLE OF NEW YORK CITY